Ольга Деркач стала другою військовою Збройних сил України, яка публічно заявила про сексуальні домагання.
Він дозволяв - і не тільки по відношенню до мене - жінок з ранку і цілувати, і обіймати,   якщо ти приходиш в кабінет,
він дозволяв собі торкатися, обіймати, під одяг засовувати руки... навіть таке дозволяв.
За 25 років жінка дослужилася до звання підполковника.
Нині 43-річна військова керує відділом фінансового забезпечення в Чернігівському військовому комісаріаті.
Ольга хотіла і далі спокійно виконувати свої обов'язки. Втім, терпіти сексуальні домагання, які тривали роками, вже не могла.
Такі натяки весь час сексуального характеру про те, що болить голова, бо сексу недостатньо в житті.
Сексом все лікується у жінок. І ще грубіші вислови...
Як розповіла DW Ольга, усе почалося п'ять років тому, коли керівником військкомату став полковник Олександр Криворучко.
Одразу було видно, що він охочий до жінок. Я бачила, як він ходить і всіх цілує. Намагався мене, а я кажу, що мене не треба.
Він каже, що всім подобається.  Всіх два рази, а я кажу: "Добре, але мене не треба цілувати".
А коли став комісаром, я зрозуміла, що треба тісніше спілкуватися, ми поговорили і розставили крапки над "і",  що служимо без всяких цих.
Я сказала, що де працюють - там не сплять, і цей мій принцип.
А потім деякий час пройшов, і його поведінка змінилася. Каже: "А я передумав".
Через те, що Ольга не приймала такі залицяння, мусила роками терпіти критику начальника та погрози зруйнувати кар'єру.
Після останніх прилюдних образ з боку керівника жінка потрапила у госпіталь, де не витримала й про все й розповіла.
У госпіталі сказала про причину. Питають: конфлікт службовий? Ні! А що трапилось? І так слово за слово.
Я не думала, що мої слова підуть так далі наверх. І коли матеріали службової перевірки направили до поліції.
І коли там почали дорозслідування, я зрозуміла, що спасіння лише там.
І дійсно, якщо вони розслідують, то треба йти. Тож, я написала заяву.
Для Ольги боротьба із сексуальними домаганнями на робочому місці у правовому полі лише починається.
Нині справу розслідує поліція. Адвокатка Ольги Тетяна Веремій обережно говорить про перспективу слідства.
Я не можу сказати, що  ці обставини замовчуються самими ЗСУ.
Я сподіваюся,  що справа дійде до суду, що підозра буде підписана і буде вручена. Доказів у нас немало, немало.
Справу вже перекваліфікували з першої частини 154-ої статті Кримінального кодексу на другу частину,
де йдеться про службову залежність від кривдника.
Саме за такою статтею мав би бути притягнутим до відповідальності інший імовірний антигерой ЗСУ - полковник Віктор Іванів.
Два роки тому його публічно звинуватила в домаганні лейтенант Валерія Сікал.
Він пропонував жінці "розважити та задобрити" не лише себе, але й інших військових, вимагав роздягтися, пити з ним алкоголь.
Попри свідчення Валерії справа досі не потрапила до суду, а самого підозрюваного просто перевели на іншу посаду.
Прокурор не бере на себе цю відповідальність: він і не закриває справу, і не вручає підозру.
Ця бездіяльність призвела до того, що Іваніва вже не можна притягнути до кримінальної справи, бо строки завершилися,
тільки виключно через те, що прокурор довго думав, які вказівки написати слідчому, щоб слідчий щось вирішив.
Адвокатка Анна Брицька не раз писала звернення в ГПУ, де вказувала на бездіяльність прокурорів у цій справі.
У відповідь отримала відписку проте, що  офіс вживає все необхідне для неупередженого розслідування у розумні строки.
Що вони називають "розумні строки"?  Да роки, це занадто довгий час,
це не допустимий час, це цинізм і знущання щодо моєї клієнтки як потерпілої в даній справі.
Чому резонансні справи замість того, щоб отримати ефективне розслідування і вирок у суді, припадають пилом у прокуратурі?
Адвокатка каже, що серед іншого прокурори віддзеркалюють ставлення суспільства, яке нерідко вважає, що в подібних випадках винні жертви.
Не так поводилися, не так посміхнулися і спровокували кривдників.
Через суспільний осуд, власне, не кривдників, а саме жертв ті й не готові говорити.
Просто немає сил плакати від того, що людей вмовляєш... Люди кажуть,
що не хочуть це згадувати, що тільки око перестало смикатися, я вже заспокоїлася. Оля, ти мене змушуєш.
А тоді, коли дали покази, дзвонили і казали, що ти вмовила нас, навіщо ми на це пішли, що це  був останній раз, коли ми це згадуємо і говоримо про це.
Так, так, було. Будеш говорити? Ні не піду, що ти у мене чоловік, діти маленькі… Така позиція…
Що це означає, на Вашу думку? Така позиція?
У суспільстві неправильне сприйняття цієї проблеми.
Соромно має бути не тим, хто це розказує. Соромно має бути тим, хто це робить. Ось і все.
На тиск, домагання і знущання з боку військових командирів до правозахисниці Ольги Решетилової скаржаться не лише жінки, але й чоловіки.
Втім, десятки випадків, які могли б оголити проблему насильства в армії, залишаються на рівні обурення у соцмережах.
Кривдники в погонах не стають в армії "нерукопожатними". Немає морального тиску на них. Вони як служили, так і служать.
Офіцери як віталися, так і вітаються з ними за руку і навпаки підтримують.
Коли почалася історія з Олею Деркач, то я від багатьох офіцерів чула: от ці баби почали тут…
І коли я запитую, чому ви не реагує на це, вони кажуть: "Якщо будемо на кожну скаргу цих бабів реагувати, то дозволимо бабам керувати армією".
Ось такі абсолютно дикі відповіді були від здавалося б притомних офіцерів.
Згідно з військовим статутом, у разі проблем на службі, військовий має звернутися до свого командира.
Є ще гаряча лінія міноборони, куди теж можна поскаржитися.
Однак вона не анонімна і після звернення інформація одразу направляється до керівника частини, який нерідко і є причиною скарги.
Ці правила не змінювалися ще з радянських часів.
Тож, у ЗСУ обіцяють, що в рамках оборонної реформи та запровадження принципів НАТО змінять військові статути.
І запевняють, що деякі кроки вже зроблені.
Є рада жіноча, є багато інструментів і механізмів, які можуть впливати.
Є пані Вікторія Арнаутова, яка є радником головнокомандувача ЗСУ з гендерних питань,
вона контролює і відслідковує всі ці моменти, тому робота є.
Такі поодинокі випадки трапляються не лише в ЗСУ - такі випадки є в будь-якій армії.
Ми використовуємо досвід інших країн і вивчаємо його і за можливістю впроваджуємо.
Зміни мають бути відчутними не лише на практиці, а й навіть у свідомості військових.
Утім, до цього ще далеко, каже Ганна Гриценко, дослідниця проєкту "Невидимий батальйон".
Політруки мають проводити якусь виховну роботу, і в даному випадку він проводить її так:
ось, дівчата, у сусідньому підрозділі когось зґвалтували. То ви, відповідно, не провокуйте. Щоб з вами такого не було.
Ось таке нам розповідали.
Переважно нам розповідали історії, які не готові поширювати в деталях,
і навіть просили, аби ми не вказували деталі, щоб їх не впізнали, що вони з нами поговорили.
Нерідко деякі висловлювання чи вимоги керівників жінки-військові навіть не сприймають як домагання чи тиск на них - просто тому, що так заведено.
Так, підполковник Ольга Деркач лише тепер усвідомила, що нестатутні обов’язки, які мала виконувати на робочому місці,
теж зазіхання на її честь та гідність. Наприклад, накривати стіл для керівника.
Бо так було заведено. Чи цілувати його під час шикування…
Всі кажуть, але ж ти теж на шикуванні підходила і цілувала його.
Ну, так, підходила і цілувала, бо ж якщо не підійдеш і не поцілуєш, то ти вже день погана, два погана, і він на тебе вже по злому дивиться.
А поцілуєш - то вже ніби нормальне ставлення. І ти думаєш, не буду собі псувати день. Підійду як всі, як вівці.
Підійду і поцілую і буду догоджати. Але внутрішньо ти це не сприймаєш.
Ольга Деркач не хоче, аби її випадок кидав тінь на всю українську армію.
Адже за всі її 25 років у війську він був єдиним, хто так поводився.
Тим часом полковник Криворучко, на якого була подана не одна скарга і проведена не одна службова перевірка,
пішов у відставку за власним бажанням з усіма виплатами і навіть подав до суду скаргу про захист честі і гідності.
А полковник Іванів і досі обіймає посаду в Генштабі ЗСУ.